whoa it's dark in here I'm glad we have
these cave lights did you charge yours
oh of course not
geez I guess we're gonna be partially in
the dark here today you know who is
partially in the dark some of our cloud
customers out there with multiple
logging platforms and they're busy
searching for who did what where and
when the great news is a Google cloud we
have a solution that will help our
customers get out of the dark by
exporting those audit events into a
popular logging platform called Splunk
you want to check it out let's do it
so the first thing we're going to need
to do is create a topic in this case
we're just going to name it GCP to
Splunk we're going to click on the
create button and the topic is going to
be created quite quickly the next step
is to create the export sink to do this
we're gonna open up a cloud shell and
then we're gonna download a script from
a Google Cloud storage bucket that has
the G cloud commands it from our
solution guide now the script is
downloaded we're gonna pass it the
argument of the organizational name and
that's important to note is because when
we run that command with the filter it
will include the children records and
that will include the folders and
projects any events underneath the org
now you'll notice that from those G
cloud commands there's a couple of
messages there and one is indicating a
new service account has been created and
it's asking for that service account to
have the pubsub publisher role the the
reason that it needs that pub/sub
publisher role is because those exported
events from the sync are going to go to
the topic so now we'll go back to the
pub sub topic will click on permissions
and we'll paste in the new service
account we're going to need to give it
that pub sub publisher role and we'll
click on add so now we have a topic we
have an export sync the next step that
we'll need to do is create a
subscription and this is the
subscription that Splunk will have to
pull those messages from the topic so
we'll click on new subscription we're
going to name it
Splunk to GCP the delivery type is going
to be pull and then we'll click on
create and just like topic that happens
pretty quickly so now we have a
subscription for spunk to pull the
messages the next thing we're going to
need to do is we're going to have to
give Splunk
permission to come into the GCB platform
and pull the messages will go up so the
IM roles will click on service accounts
and we'll click on create' service
account and here we're going to name it
Splunk to GCP and we're going to give it
a couple different roles that are
required one is going to be the project
viewer role the second role will be of
course the pub sub subscriber role so
now we have two roles of viewer and pub
sub subscriber we're gonna click on
furnish a new private key with a key
type of JSON and click create you'll
notice on the left hand side that that
JSON key has been downloaded and we have
a couple warnings there about protecting
that key and it's very important that
you consider integrating this process
into your secrets management platform
because this will give access to the GCP
platform and also shred any local copies
that you have there so now that we
understand that we have to secure this
key will click close and we'll head back
to the topic and try to publish a
message will click on topics and we'll
click on publish a message and we'll
type in help I'm in a cave with clowns
because that's not scary and we'll click
on publish the next thing we could do is
we can leverage the metrics Explorer in
stackdriver to check out that messages
are being published successfully and can
be used for troubleshooting in the
future so that's it we now have audit
events from the Google cloud platform
ready to be pulled into your spunk
instance making it easy to answer the
question of who did what where and when
so this does make it easy for security
ops teams to have one place to look for
audit events you got it don't forget to
Like comment and subscribe and if you're
working on any cool projects and would
like to get in contact with us click on
the link in the description thanks for
watching
[Music]